[Music]
it's a pleasure to be here at next with
all of you
I'm projector I'm a product manager and
cloud networking like Columbus I am a
manager in the network specialist team
so we work with customers like
yourselves for all things networking on
your journey journey to Google cloud so
what we wanted to do was to start this
talk by introducing you to our cloud
load balancing family we are going to
get we are going to spend most of this
session getting to know five members
which is global HTTP HTTP load balancing
SSL proxy TCP proxy and then we've got
two other flavors that are regional
which is Network lb and internal elf elf
or lb and one of the things that many of
you know but some of you may not is that
these load balancing flavors actually
underpin a lot of things are specially
load balancing on the compute engine
side or whether it's cloud storage or
whether it's the GK side which is a
kubernetes side or even yourself managed
kubernetes on GCB so so we thought let's
start with the basics which is which was
the first flavor that we have and then
Mike give us a tour of network load
balancer sure thanks so two years ago we
published a paper that revealed the
architectural details of the Maglev now
the Maglev has been around for a while
it's our in-house developed all software
load balancer that runs on standard
Google hardware this load balancer has
been hand handling the majority of
Google's traffic since 2008 and is a key
part of our architecture maglevs handled
traffic as they come into our data
centers they direct traffic across our
front-end infrastructure and they're
also exposed to you as our network load
balancer for Google cloud so the network
load balancer when you create a network
load balancer we use forwarding rules
that basically direct TCP and UDP
traffic across regional backends that
can be auto scaled using hashing so it's
a network based load balancer we look at
the source test port IP and protocol and
you can you know manipulate the hashing
algorithm as you see fit
when you create a forwarding rule you
get a VIP or virtual IP address that
originates from a regional network block
wherever you're you tie that forwarding
rule to your back ends so this VIP is
anycast out our global points of
presence but the back ends are regional
meaning you cannot have back ends that
span multiple regions this is a
pass-through load balancer so your back
ends are going to see the original
client request it's not doing any TLS
offload or proxying so traffic gets you
know directly routed to your VMs and
that's where you can use the Google
firewall to control or filter access to
the backend VMs so in this diagram you
see we have three regional backends
three forwarding rules we have my in
California Bob in New York in Shannon
Singapore and they're all connecting
into their back-end resources which is
my app test and travel but if Shen were
to connect into the US West's back-end
again would ingress that traffic closest
to Shen in Singapore because that range
is anycast out our network and then we'd
route that traffic to the regional
back-end so let's take a little bit of a
deeper look under the hood of the maglev
so on the left here you see a
traditional middle edge proxy load
balancing design which are typically
deployed in active standby pairs or
highly available pairs they're scaled up
as more capacity as needed and typically
if you have massive spikes in traffic
this needs to be pre warmed to prepare
for the influx of traffic on the right
hand you can see the maglev architecture
so again this is an all software based
solution that runs on our standard
servers and it's horizontally scalable
the way this works is in a traditional
sense a load balancer is primary or
active for for its VIP right in the
Maglev architecture we announce all VIPs
to our edge routers via ecmp so we'll
distribute flows based on hashing so
equal cost routing to our maglevs
the maglevs will then use consistent
hashing what this means is as maglevs
our load balancers are added to the pool
we'll get consistent results as
that back-end is selected the maglevs
then encapsulate that traffic based on
the virtual network idea for the
customer and send that to the back-end
service and then we use direct service
direct server return to send that
traffic directly into our edge routers
so the maglevs are not in path for the
return flow so I want to recap what
features we have with our network load
balancer again it's a regional solution
so we have high availability by
deploying your backends and multiple
zones it does not look at layer 7 at
load balances TCP and UDP the backends
will see the original client request so
there's no need to pass an
x-forwarded-for header or use proxy
protocol to inform the backends of what
the original client request was and you
can control this access with the fir VPC
firewall we balance based on two three
or five tupple and you can get affinity
by using two or three tuple hashing so
that way the source of fusing source IP
dust IP you'll always choose the same
back end we healthcheck the back ends
and this is a very high performance
solution so we published a paper we
handled one million requests per second
with no pre-warming what it does not
provide so there's no global backends
for the network load balancer we also
only support ipv4 so there's no ipv6
support for the network load balancer no
layer 7 traffic routing and also no TLS
termination or offload so with that I'll
hand it over to projector thanks Mike so
that is how so we had the network load
balancer and then given all of the
reasons that Mike spoke spoke through
that's how we decided to go and build
the global load balancer now most of you
are familiar with the kind of load
balancing that you see in other public
clouds and the load balancers are
regional and what that means is poor
region you need a virtual IP for your
load balancer and then your backends are
simply in that reason as region as well
so now imagine you wanted to set up your
service in three regions and then you
would need to go put three webs and then
obviously you need a DNS load balancer
or global server load balancer to go
pick one of those wimps for your given
client
and this is actually several issues so
as an example if something were to go
down first of all your dns load balancer
has to go and understand something went
down the second thing is your local DNS
to the client could go and cache the IPS
and that could result in suboptimal
selection and the other thing is imagine
you ran out of capacity in one region
the regions are silos so the load
balancer in one region cannot leverage
the capacity in another region this
obviously would not have worked for
Google services and so this is when we
thought why don't we rethink how global
load balancing is done and the idea was
to not depend on the DNS load balancer
to go do load balancing for you so now
imagine first of all you don't build out
the load balancer using managed VMs or
instances or servers instead we just put
all of Google's global edge
infrastructure and we put load balancing
logic there and this was along with a
bunch of different systems that
interoperate to do load balancing for
your clients which means it doesn't
matter where you put your application
instances you get a single front-end
whip you get worldwide capacity because
now that whip is fronting all of your
capacity across all of your deployments
and then you get cross region failover
and so on and so forth and one of the
really nice things about the load
balancer is that it's very tightly
coupled with our autoscaler which means
as your traffic grows it will scale up
your back-end instances and then as your
traffic herbs it will scale them down as
well it's also like one really nice side
effect of it is the VIP becomes or our
global VIP becomes a very nice place to
go apply all your global policies and
the other thing is you don't have a
choke point because these are not just
point implementations with VMs and so on
so a really nice way to think about you
know what is this global load balancing
really look like so often we have
customers who will start off with a
single region and they will go deploy a
backends there they will configure the
load balancing whip now it's very likely
that as your service grows in popularity
you will need to bring up application
instances in another region and so as
you can see here France Bob in New York
comes on board all you need to do is go
our application instances in our region
u.s. East you don't need to change the
whip you don't need to put a DNS load
balancer because you still have only one
whip in this case it's two hundred one
one one and then you can just expand
wherever Google has data centers by
simply putting instances there but as
you can notice there was no change to
the whip there was no change to your DNS
server and you definitely did not need
any of the things related to DNS load
balancing one of the other things which
I spoke about was the capacity that you
get so in this case for instance let's
say your instances in Singapore are
overloaded so Shannon Singapore would be
very seamlessly directed to any of the
other available instances and it's also
possible that the California instances
for your app are overloaded and so your
users could be overflowed back into New
York and once the capacity is available
because basically the autoscaler scaled
up then the clients would be brought
back so note of people ask us like what
does this look like under the hood so
because all of our mental models of load
balancers are these boxes this is
actually what the global load balancer
looks like under the hood we have a
tiered edge so we do part of the load
balancing and termination at our tier
one and then we do some of the load
balancing remaining remainder of the
load balancing logic at the tier two so
that's what you see the two-tier
architecture and then then your
application instances are in the last
which say is like instances there that's
what that's where you would be running
your application software the other
thing that a lot of people ask us is so
like you have all of these instances and
how does the load balancer go distribute
traffic what it does is it fills up the
local region to capacity for a given
flying then it will fill up basically
all the zones within a region then it'll
if you're out of capacity in a region it
will overflow to the closest region and
then within the zone itself at round
robins I you you can totally forget all
of this because you don't need to worry
about this this happens automatically
but the key takeaway is as long as you
have available capacity in the region
that's closest to your user your user
will land up there you will overflow or
you'll fail over only if there's some
issue or capacity issue or availability
issue in the region closest to the user
the other thing that
wanted to walk you through his this is
what's under the hood so what is the
data model for the global load balancer
look like so you have essentially the
VIP which is the global forwarding rule
then you have the proxy so if you're
running HTTP traffic your proxy would be
HTTP or it's HTTPS or SSL or any of the
other TCP and so on so forth then you've
got the backend side of it this is where
you're actually putting your application
instances and so a service maps to a
back-end service and then that could
have application instances within
instance groups in one or more regions
depending on where your users are so
what this was a whirlwind tour but what
I wanted to do was Mike why don't you
take us on a tour of this through a demo
be happy to thanks projector so today
we're gonna be interfacing with an HTTP
global load balancer deployment it's
live up and running and I wanted to take
a few minutes to talk through the
components and how they're configured
and really solidify that the object
model that project I just spoke of and
what's really cool is if you're one of
the select few who are online during
this conference on the network you can
connect to this fancy front-end we built
for you so if we can switch to the demo
alright so here we're in Google's cloud
console we're going to navigate to
network services and this is where we'll
configure load balancing DNS and CDN in
this exercise we'll be taking a look at
our load balancer as you can see we have
three in this project the first two
we'll get to later the third one is what
we're going to go through today this is
an HTTP load balancer so we're gonna
drill in a little bit on what's
configured so in the cloud console it
really breaks this object model down
into three components the first is the
front end right hosting path rules which
is basically like we'll look at the URL
request and route that to the
appropriate back-end service and then
the back end service and I'll go I'll go
through each component in its
configuration here so we just spent a
bunch of time talking about a single VIP
there's two here you might be saying
Mike what gives it's because the first
VIP is for ipv4 the second VIP is for
ipv6 so basically for the domain
WSP networking.com we're gonna take in
HTTP traffic and direct this to our
target proxy so when you create an HTTP
front-end Global forwarding rule you
need to have a certificate so we support
S&I but I kind of cheated here and this
is a little bit of a sneak peak I used a
Google manage search so this is going to
manage the lifecycle this cert for me
super easy I just you know when I
deployed the cert I configured the
domain and I pointed using cloud DNS I
pointed an A and a quad a record to
these IP addresses and in it deployed
SSL policy we'll get to in a little bit
we're gonna we're gonna additively do
further ins talk some some additional
things to this environment will secure
the environment in the network here is
premium this is our default tier this
means that these these VIP ranges come
from a global pool of addresses that
will anycast out our global pops right
so kind of back to the DNS thing that
project I mentioned right one a record
one quad a record route clients via any
casts just BGP routing to the closest
front end so for mayor we'll talk about
host and path rules so in this
environment it's pretty simple you don't
need to configure these for the for the
HTTP load balancer it's kind of
important right that's why you might
want to layer seven load balancer what
these do is that we look at the incoming
URL and direct the traffic to the
appropriate back-end service based on
this matter so you can do path matches
in this environment it's pretty simple
let me zoom in here for make it a little
easier see
so anything unmatched will go to our web
back-end service anything slash secure
is going to go to our secure back-end
service the backend services themselves
so these are made up of a collection of
instance groups the instance groups can
be deployed in any one of our 20 regions
in this environment I picked us West one
fairly close in Europe West one but in
addition to adding your instance groups
into your back-end service it's also a
collection of configuration so you're
gonna want to group your applications
appropriately into back-end services for
this reason so the first thing that's
configure
the back-end services your endpoint
protocol so we pitched TLS everywhere I
was a little bit of lazy I did HTTP but
it's fairly common to use salsa inserts
in the backend because you know your
clients are connecting into the
front-end proxy you'll notice the named
port where this is important and this is
a configuration that's part of the
instance group is that this is basically
a key pair so if you wanted the load
balancer to direct traffic on your
instance to your instances on the
backend on you know a non-standard port
you'll set a named port in the instance
group associate that to the port that
you want to receive traffic on and in
the backends would receive traffic from
the front-end or from the Google load
balancer on that port time-outs also
very important so if you're running web
sockets or long-lived HTTP connections
you're probably going to want a timeout
of greater than 30 seconds this is a
fairly static page so I didn't muck with
this at all we enabled cloud CDN it's a
simple checkbox and your back-end
service configuration so if you had you
know dynamic content that you didn't
want to cache you could leave it off for
a back-end service associated with that
and then you know enable it for your
static content the other thing I forgot
to mention is in your host and path
rules you can also direct to back-end
service or also a back-end bucket so
I've wanted to just mention that real
quick the backend service health check
is is it's configured on the backend
service so we're using a basic HTTP
check for our back-end services to make
sure that they're healthy and then
there's some advanced configurations so
we can configure such an affinity
connection draining or timeout so
basically how long if we drain or if
we're going to be removing a VM how long
we're going to keep those connections
active we can associate a security
policy it's a little bit of a teaser
there we'll do that later
and also identity aware proxy which
we'll talk about the other thing is you
can also add custom headers so if we
wanted to insert a header have have the
HTTP load balancer inform us of say like
geolocation or some custom header we can
insert those on a per back-end service
so this back-end service consists of
three instance groups you'll see
everything's healthy which is great you
got to love demos we have
back in we have an instance group in
Europe West one in u.s. West one you'll
notice we set the auto-scaling to 80% of
our target which is 300 requests per
second per VM so auto-scaling will be
triggered in this case 80% of 300 which
is 240
assuming that capacity is 100% this is
an additional knob that's really
important for canary or a bee releases
so you might notice this new web you
know instance group this is really like
if I want to spin up a test and direct a
subset of traffic to this instance group
I set the capacity for 10% so 10% of 300
so about 30 requests per second will go
to this new instance group so great for
canary an additional control now the
next thing I want to do is contrast this
the load balancing configuration with
the configuration of an instance group
itself so we'll pick an instance group
which is uswest 1 and let me just zoom
out a little bit and we'll edit this
group so in the instance group itself
here's where you specify the key pair
so we're mapping HTTP to port 80 we
could do you know 8080 on the back end
if we wanted to or 8 443 this instance
group is built off a template which
basically calls in a custom image trying
to keep the boot time for a relatively
short weave auto scaling on based on
HTTP load balancing usage we can also
use CPU usage or our custom metrics but
we want the autoscaler
because we see the requests per second
we want the auto scale it to trigger
auto scaling we have a minimum of one
instance a maximum of 10 and the
cooldown period is relatively important
what this means is it's a time we're
gonna wait before we collect statistics
on this instance so if you have
long-running startup scripts you're
gonna want to know how long your
instance takes to boot and set
appropriately in your cooldown period
the other thing is Auto healing so Auto
healing is the ability to have an
additional health check that will
recreate the VM if it goes unhealthy or
it's unresponsive typically your auto
healing Chow health check you want to
relax a little bit because it's a more
expensive operation to you know reboot a
VM and rebuild VM versus just taking it
out of the healthy available
Poole for your back-end but that's there
and it's turned on here with an initial
delay of 30 seconds there's a similar to
the cooldown period we're gonna wait 30
seconds before we health check this back
nvm so we've gone through the
configuration another thing I have set
up here is is some load so I want to
show just a little bit of monitoring our
load balancer so jump back in here so
here's our web back-end service so I
have to load generators one in North
America one in Europe both are sent in
about a thousand requests per second and
what this graph shows us is that traffic
arriving at our North American front end
locations are always being directed to
our US West one back-end service or
instance groups now this is this goes to
the distribution right we're always
going to select the healthiest back-end
with available capacity you can see a
small subset of traffic is being
directed to our you know canary release
site which is our new web back-end
instance instance group and then in
Europe all those requests are being
served by the Europe West one instance
group and then the last thing we'll do
is let's just we can connect to the demo
site so hopefully some of you were able
to access this so it's a pretty simple
web page the client IP is the original
client IP so originating from probably
some NAT gateway here at the Moscone
load balancer IP is the load balancer
VIP the proxy IP is basically the
connections so the actual IP address
that the VM back-end will see once that
connections proxied and these are known
ranges of addresses that you're going to
want to allow through your firewall your
VM firewalls we'd see the host name
we're connecting into we're in San
Francisco we're connecting to us West
one I'd be a little alarmed if this was
Europe and I could see the region end
zone so with that let's jump back to the
slides let's talk a little bit about
container networking so for those
running containerized workloads on
Google cloud I want to talk about how
we've enhanced the experience and really
made containers first-class citizens
with regard to our load-balancing
offerings so I'm really excited to talk
about Network endpoint groups so what
network endpoint groups are they're a
collection of network endpoints so
fundamentally this maps to a port and IP
pair so there's a precursor to network
endpoint groups
VMs can have multiple ranges associated
to them so we use alias IP ranges and in
that sense a VM can host multiple
containers with VPC routable IP
addresses along with serving ports so
now with network infant groups we can
target these IPS along with serving port
as an endpoint health check and load
balance accordingly and much more
accurately without network employ groups
so the diagram on the left here
apologize it's a little choppy shows a
kubernetes deployment without network
endpoint groups and one of the things
that we'll see is that the load balancer
targets nodes not endpoints not
containers themselves so what happens is
traffic arrives at the load balancer we
select the backend node and then with
kubernetes engine we have queue proxy
which basically configures a bunch of IP
tables rules almost as a secondary load
balancer to distribute traffic to the
back-end pods so depending on how many
pods so it's like let's assume you have
an equal distribution of pods across
your nodes well you have a 1 divided by
n which is the number of nodes chance
that a node outside of the the local
node your traffic arrives that will be
selected for this load balancer so in
this case traffic comes into the node IP
tables will do some masquerading and
send that traffic to a pod located on
another node
it also sword stats so you have these
extra hops then the traffic returns from
the pod back through the original back
to the original node and then back to
the the load balancer and then back to
the client so it's fairly suboptimal now
you can turn on a mode which is known as
local only but which will just target
the nodes I'm sorry the pods local to
the node that the traffic arrives on but
even then you're not going to get an
even distribution
on the right-hand diagram we show
Network endpoint groups in this model
the load balancer sends traffic directly
to the port and IP pairs for the
containers and this is enabled with a
simple annotation right this is an alpha
feature but with one simple annotation
you can eliminate a lot of hops and I'm
going to show a quick demo on this later
the next bit I want to talk about is
multi multi cluster ingress so if you
have an application running on
kubernetes engine in in different
regions so you have different regional
clusters set up but at the same
application you can now deploy a multi
cluster ingress which basically you can
register your container clusters to and
create a unified ingress that can load
balanced clients traffic using all that
global load balancing magic to the
appropriate container cluster so this is
an enhancement to our cube control
interface so with cube mci
you can create this new ingress that
will map multiple clusters to a single
load balancer alright so here's the demo
environment again I want to show Network
endpoint groups and I'll prove this
there's there's no smoke and mirrors
going on here so I have one cluster
which is cluster a that is deployed with
Network endpoint groups so we have a
simple web application that's just
returning its hostname
we have load generator so we're going to
blast a bunch of traffic to it and we're
going to observe some some monitoring
metrics on this the other cluster is
deployed in the same zone uswest one a
same number of nodes same application
same load testing characteristics so
we're sending 50 concurrent clients
connecting into this this environment
but this is not using Network endpoint
groups all right so let's jump back into
our demo
all right so back in the cloud console I
just want to give you a quick tour in
the environment so you can't call me out
later so here you can see our two
clusters they both have three nodes
they're basically identical as far as
the deployments we have in those
clusters you can see our network end
point group demo app as five replicas in
our cluster a which is our network end
point group cluster the nan nega the app
is running in cluster B and then if we
look at the services both of these
clusters are again running five pods and
then we have ingress of the HTTP load
balancer so if we jump over to the HTTP
load balancer screen you'll see that in
our network imprint group cluster you
notice that the backend service is
targeting and network endpoint groups so
these are built zonally so if we had a
regional cluster you would see a network
endpoint group per zone but again these
are port and IP pairs and if we jump
back to the nan nega you can see that
the load balancer is targeting the nodes
right so you know iptables is involved
masquerading packets so if we look at
stack driver monitoring there's a couple
of interesting observations so I'm
capturing or charting two metrics the
first is requests per second
and the other is aggregate network
traffic on the backend nodes so even
though the load testing is the exact
same you'll notice we're able to send
about 10% more connections to the
network endpoint group cluster I think
this is you know don't take my word for
this but I believe this is because these
that the transactions are finishing
faster so that the performance traffic
generator is able to pump more traffic
to the network endpoint group cluster
this is key here though you'll notice
that the network endpoint group cluster
has about half of the aggregate traffic
as the non neg network end point group
cluster so this is substantial right
this is all a factor of eliminating
those hops but the other thing is like
imagine if you're running a regional
stur where you have nodes and different
zones let's cut them out to huge cost
savings because you're not getting
charged zonal egress between between the
notes right so pretty quick demo there
hopefully that was helpful I'll hand it
back over to projector
great thanks Mike so what we did is so
far we wanted to provide you a very
close look at global load balancing and
then our container load balancing the
next half of this presentation we'll
just quickly walk you through all of the
features many of these have actually
have their own sessions but the idea is
that you're exposed to a lot of these
features so the first one of those is
internal load balancing because not
every service of yours needs to have a
public-facing web so that's the first
one you can see a very traditional
internal load balancer where you've got
a client in RFC 1918 space load balancer
rip in RFC 1918 space and a back-end
this is also traditional three-tier app
where the first tier is essentially
public-facing and then the internal load
balancer is used for rest of the tiers
the most interesting bit actually about
the internal load balancer is that there
is really no internal load balancer so
between your clients and your backends
there is really no middle proxy sitting
and doing load balancing we have
Andromeda which is our network
virtualization stack and then that
plumps the client along with health
information so that the client itself
can go pick the optimal back-end so that
way there's no choke point in your
network with internal load balancer the
other thing you know when you start with
private services the next set of things
that you're going to go tackle is
essentially securing the edge because
all of your internet facing services are
going to get ddosed and these would be
either infrastructure DDoS attacks or
these would be even application level
attacks so we have a bunch like when you
actually secure your network you want to
do it all the way from V PC to your edge
network and we have several great
sessions on each of these one thing I
want to point out is one best practice
is to put TLS wherever you can we don't
charge extra for TLS so that should be
your default the second thing is if you
have this need for multiple certs
we have a feature that lets you
multiple suits on a given load balancer
and then many of you complained about
the toil of procuring suits so we do
have managed suits which are an alpha
they will be available in beta ng this
year next the other thing is many of you
said can I turn off TLS 1.0 because I
need to pass my PCI compliance tests so
we also have custom as SSL policies
available for you either you can
outsource you can select what kind of
policy you want and you can outsource
management to Google or then you can go
create your own custom ones if your IT
department has like certain regulations
around those the other feature that I
also want to call out is as a best
practice you should be turning on global
lb with TLS all of the features we
talked about cloud armor and then if you
have if you're controlling access based
on user identities you would also layer
in the identity aware proxy so all of
these work together pretty well and then
also if cloud armor sees drop traffic
and identity of various proxies is allow
traffic it's a combined thing so it'll
essentially drop the traffic so they all
work pretty nicely along with each other
what I wanted to do now is and of course
like we're not going to deep dive into
the features of cloud armor we had
several sessions on those it goes all
the way from IP blacklists whitelist to
sophisticated layer 7 type defense but
we wanted to do a quick demo with Mike
all right back again so today or for
this session we're going to be tying
some security policy to our existing
demo that we just went through so I I
pin network security here so we're going
to be configuring an SSL policy as well
as a cloud armor policy and I'll show
you how that gets attached to your load
balancers to provide additional
protection so we'll start with cloud
armor you can see I have a cloud armor
security policy here this is a simple
policy but you can always add to these
later so this is titled allow conference
net blocks so the idea here is that this
is an IP whitelist blacklist policy
so the rule set is fairly simple we're
gonna allow any so I got the Moscone
Network ranges hopefully these are
accurate um hopefully you get online to
test these so basically we're gonna
allow this so you can see some ipv4
ranges are there along with an ipv6
range and then we're gonna deny
everything else right so so if you have
an application that you know you want to
make sure your explicit as far as which
app which IP addresses are allowed to
access that this allows you to obviously
filter that at the edge and don't worry
about it on your back-end VM so we take
care of it so once the rules created you
know we've added our rule set which is
fairly simple here with that with the
deny at the end though order that the
rules are evaluated is from low to high
so low is the first so we created a
priority 100 rule here so we have some
room to grow we attach this policy to
targets so you can attach this policy to
a single target or multiple targets
I already attach this policy to our
secure back-end service so the idea is
if you are on the local network here you
should have access to slat wwhd SW w GP
networking comm slash secure and make
sure there's a there's a tailing slash
there to for access if you're not you're
not going to get access so one way I can
prove this is I'm on the network right
now let's open up a new tab and connect
to our edge security demo and you can
see we got there the page looks a little
bit different there's about the extent
to the customizations I did
but again this is connecting into the
other back-end back-end service one way
to test that this doesn't work is to use
our cloud shell so a cloud shell is
basically a it's a jump host
pre-installed with our software
development kits so basically it's an
easy way to interface with your project
programmatically so it's a Linux host so
we'll just curl to the secured back-end
service and who thinks I'm going to be
able to connect I hope not
and you can see I got a 403 so the
actual error response is configurable
you can send a 403 of 404 not found or
502 so in this in this rule I had
configured a 403
so that's cloud armor a very simple
example of cloud armor in the key
takeaway here is that it's a tied to
your it's attached to your back-end
service so if we wanted to connect to to
you know the kind of the naked URL here
it would work just fine it's because we
don't have the policy tied to that
back-end service SSL policies is projec
dimensioned is a powerful tool to
enforce compliance so say if we wanted
to follow PCI guidance and say all right
I only want my clients to connect into
my environment with a minimum of TLS 1.2
it's kind of like cloud armor right you
create the policy but in this case you
attach it to the target proxy and the
global forwarding rules so we've created
a policy that specifies minimum TLS
version is 1.2 with the restricted
profile but you know you can create
custom profiles and explicitly allow or
disallow ciphers we also have a modern
profile to a support a wide set of
clients then we also have a compatible
profile which is a little bit more loose
where you can create your own so for
this we created minimum TLS version of
1.2 and we attach this to the load
balancer so now if we do a curl command
but specify the TLS version so let's try
to connect with version 1.0 you see we
get necessary to call for an error if we
try 1.2 same error right we only want to
support 1.3 so if we do one dot I'm
sorry we only support 1.2 or both I'm
some 1.2 when we specify that for the
TLS version works no problem right so
with that I'll hand it back to projector
so again the next set of features are
I'm going to put some of the work on you
and that after this session do go and
check out all of these features because
they do bring really good benefits to
your services the the main thing after
you've done you know putting your
services in place and then you've
secured the services the next thing you
want to do is optimize and I think the
first thing that people talk about
optimizing is for latency so the first
we already spoke about the global Elbe
which spoke about the two-tiered
architecture but the main takeaway is
your SSL termination happens at the edge
and that saves a lot in terms of latency
the second thing is that once your first
handshake is done then essentially after
that the connections are maintained and
so your next handshake like you're not
really doing a handshake all the way to
the end but for all of your subsequent
connections you're essentially saving on
round trips so you got this just by
putting the global load balancer one of
the really good ways to get just shave
down more of your latency is if your
content is cacheable you would go to a
non CDN so we have cloud CDN which is
our native offering and you can turn it
on with a single check box so that's
like if you have a load balancer you can
just turn on a check box as you can see
there and then you can enable it
there is also public report which is
www.cdc.gov l - reports where selects is
measured cloud sealian against other
providers and then you can see that it
does really well in terms of low latency
high throughput and availability the
other thing is something that we've been
thinking about at Google for a long time
like how do you go and make the web
faster and some of the key points I
wanted to call out so we spoke about the
infrastructure we spoke about the global
elbe there are two additional things
that I want you to look at one is HTTP 2
which essentially goes and improves HTTP
and then there is quic which is a
protocol which is over UDP and in fact
if you are using a Chrome browser during
the route during the day you've already
used quick and you know it does some
really cool things so like if you think
of why your latency is there it's
because of things like head-of-line
blocking so if there is a bunch of
features built into quick
which actually stands for quick UDP
internet connections that help you bring
the latency down I'm going to show you
how you would configure it a lot of
times people will say we support HTTP 2
the first thing you need to see is from
where to where
so we support HTTP 2 from trying to the
load balancer and then load balancer to
the back-end and you would need that to
run G RPC same way with quick we support
from client towards the load balancer
and we are the first cloud to actually
support that the first major public
cloud to do that and what it really
gives you is this so when we turned on
quick for our CDN you can see the sharp
jump in throughput because you brought
down latency so you can essentially have
more connections and then what you see
on the right is how do you how did it
bring down this latency and you can see
that the handshake looks much smaller
when you have quick vs. without quick so
we have a blog post that we posted which
describes all of these details as well
but that is one of the features you
should be looking at looking at to bring
down your latency now these are some of
the features that Mike already spoke
about which is network tiers so when
your traffic egress is out of Google
Cloud you're paying the outbound data
transfer costs you should by default use
the premium tier because that takes your
return traffic over Google's global
network but you may have services which
for instance are a free tier for you or
you may have services that are not
mission-critical and if you want to
bring down the cost there you can
actually go configure the load balancer
to use just like other public clouds
just standard ISP transit which is not
Google's network to go back to your user
and so the main thing we want to do is
that we wanted you to have choice per
workload so you can actually have this
configuration per load balancer if you
want to or if you just want to put it at
the project level which is our thing
which holds all of your load balances
you can do that as well this one is
again something that Mike spoke about
which is when you configure your
application instances we have a feature
called user-defined request headers
which lets you put things such as client
geolocation or RTT or TLS information
and then send it to your backends so
then your backends can use that
and they can use it in their application
logic to make optimized decisions so my
recap everything we spoke about all
right
so tried to as she walks off the stage
all right some of these might actually
be new but but just kind of a cheat
sheet right so that the first thing in
general right choose the optimal load
balancer we have a few different
solutions and not every there's not one
size fits all right so factors you want
to consider do I need ipv6 support right
do I need TLS offload is it an internal
versus external application regional
versus global do your backends need true
client IP right so these are gonna guide
you to the right load balancer make sure
you don't just start deploying without
knowing what you're getting yourself
into the other thing is optimized for
latency right so we have 20 regions
deploy your workloads in the region
closest to you users and if you're using
a globally global load balancer deploy
to multiple regions closest to your
users and use modern protocols right
like quick HTTP to write all these
things are great you know improve
performance and also help in you know
lossy environments where the connections
might not be great
secure your service so there's a few
bits here right as projected mention use
TLS everywhere standardize on that use
the V PC firewall to augment your
security policy so health checks come
from known ranges any of our proxy load
balancers traffic comes from known
rangers ranges lock that down these
things are predictable secure at the
edge with cloud armor right make sure
you're using that functionality to
eliminate you know additional security
measures have a defense and depth
strategy and offload some of that to our
edge the other thing is in this a common
one so your VMs do not need public IP
addresses and any of our load balancer
solutions right even though you know
that the GFE IP if you recall when it
connected back into the backend lock
your firewall down to that range right
there's a no need to expose your
backends with a public IP address
optimized for auto scaling right no the
profile of your application know how you
want
skel if you have a dual headed service
so if you have an instance group that's
a back-end of two load balancers really
think through how you want to scale that
right you wanna use a custom metric
because the load balancers will scale
independently understand and optimize
health checks right try to health check
as close to the application as you can
and you know as I mentioned earlier use
you know it's it's less expensive
operation to remove a VM from a pool of
back-end services and then use auto
healer to reboot that VM should it
become unresponsive but relax those
timers a little bit the other thing I'll
say here is that our health checks can
be quite chatty so if you know if you're
doing logging on your on your back-end
VM just make sure you're aware of our
ranges so you can treat them accordingly
on your logs for the ILP or network load
balancer there's UDP considerations so
these load balancers for UDP so if you
think you're gonna get fragmented UDP
packets be careful with 5-tuple hashing
the reason is you can lose the
destination port as packets arrive on
our load balancer and those packets will
be dropped so you might be better off
using a different load balancing
algorithm the other thing is with UDP
that's a common thing I see make sure
you're listening on the actual VIP so
what happens is if you put with the
network load balancer the i/o be the
VIPs are known by the VMS they get
installed as a linux route you want to
listen on that VIP on your back-end VMs
for UDP traffic use five tuple hashing
for the best entropy a lot of times
people will load test the network load
balancer or the ilb and they'll send the
same source test port IP and protocol
and they're like why isn't stuff getting
distributed across my back ends you know
you wouldn't want to throw a variety of
traffic at it just to see traffic get
balanced because it's using hashing I
use two or three tuple hashing for
session affinity for the global load
balancers secure at the edge use
capacity scaler for a B deployments it's
a very powerful tool where you could you
know set capacity an additional measure
to start directing traffic to new new
new builds so at the appropriate
connection timeout and I used cookie or
IP based affinity for session of
persistence
so with that I'll project to take us
home
Thanks so you know we spoke about
everything that exists today and we I
mean the next question is so what's next
and load balancing and we see had an
entire session or not just prior to this
one but if you attended any of the
sessions in this conference there were
two main trends one was monoliths -
micro services and then the second one
is almost everybody has at least an
on-prem deployment and Google Cloud or
Google Cloud in another cloud or maybe
all three and you know delivering
services that span this or even taking
your monolith when you chop it - micro
services you sure you get agility and so
on and so forth but it's still really
hard to deliver those services and so
cloud services platform which are which
was our announcement in our keynote
yesterday is attempting to solve those
problems where instead of giving you
point products we are putting them all
together into a platform so you can
actually go and then build these pipe
later multi cloud services I wanted to
add two new bits that we announced in
the previous session one is the traffic
director and then how it interoperates
with envoy which is a service proxy I'm
not going to go into the details of it
but the simple thing I wanted to show is
like this is a service you brought in
the notion of a service mesh so that's
where a lot of this load balancing is
headed - we're just like you know in the
old days you took Hardware boxes and you
separated the control and the data plane
you wring exactly the same two services
where your control plane is now the
service proxy and then your data plane
your data penis the service proxy and
then your control plane is your service
management infrastructure one of the
most popular service proxies that we see
in uses envoy and our previous session
was centered around that so if you get a
chance or do look at the Envoy proxy and
we like it because first of all it's
high performance it provides a bunch of
features that would be required for your
services and then the third thing is
that also it is very modern so it's
supporting things like a sheeted tree it
should you be do from the get-go so the
moment you can put a proxy next to your
existing service or application logic
the way you build services can be fairly
uniform because now you can do it the
same way this is the the announcement
that I want you to go and look at later
which is traffic director so what
exactly does traffic director do let me
show you a picture here you're so used
to global load balancing with our global
load balancer we spent a big chunk of
time talking about that we want to bring
that same capability to micro-services
and so what you can see here is there's
the shopping cart app you've got the
front end the shopping cart app and the
payment but your instances for your
micro services are in two different
regions so one is in US central so our
data centers are in Iowa and then the
other one is actually in Singapore and
what this means is but it's not that
there are two services they're literally
one service with instances in both
regions and then the traffic director is
the one that's managing those proxies
that you see sitting on each of those
instances and that's the one that's
feeding intelligence of our global or
balancing to those proxies so it's a
departure from the traditional way where
the server side did the load balancing
now the intelligence is with the traffic
director which is feeding your
client-side proxy but then go pick the
optimal back-end for the next service so
this is what you see and then the reason
it's important is this this exactly
matches what I spoke about for global
load balancing but in the context of
micro services so you can overflow you
can do fail overs and your services will
be much more resilient in this case and
like everything else I mean if there was
one takeaway from this conference you
already know that Google is big big on
hybrid cloud and so in the future we do
want to provide traffic director for
your workloads which are not in Google
cloud and then the last thing that we
also want to do is with all of this we
fit into the CSP architecture so you do
have this really need a nice platform
that lets you go and build services at
scale and like with not much toil so it
was a whirlwind deep dive but thank you
for coming and we hope you got something
out of this session thank you
[Music]